what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are currently on site in Topanga
Canyon visiting Bernard Gunther hello
thank you for coming on the show again
it's been such a pleasure being here in
your home and speaking with you in this
of course you pick an incredibly
beautiful part of the Los Angeles area
to live in
that's completely separated from the
craziness of the city the metropolitan
city so Bernard is as you guys know the
founder of piercing the veil of reality
we've had him on the show before we are
gonna be unpacking uh some more of the
nuance and some more of the content
these beautiful bird chirps that are
happening right now I love it so Bernard
has a webinar that's coming up for
everyone that's interested we have the
link in the bio and Bernards gonna be
unpacking so many important concepts
there and let's just let's walk through
some of some of some of the stuff that
we've been talking about that we think
is just really important to voice to
more people the idea of self work and
being on this path to awakening is
something that you write about and talk
about a lot includes things like the
artistic expressions integrating
wounding aligning with this higher force
so yes so tell us tell us about that
well the best place to start from is
really looking at what's going on in the
world right now it has been going on for
a while we see these are crazy times you
know a lot of poor polarization
people fighting each other people
attached to certain ideologies believes
political systems and everybody thinks
they're believer systems the best and
then trying to convince the other person
intellectually right about all these
things right and we all everybody's
coming from well-meaning place everybody
you know has you know most people anyway
have their heart in the right place so
to speak but if you kind of look deeper
into it all you know there's only so
much can change by externally trying to
change the world or another person and
most often we cannot
each people by intellectual discourse
alone you know you can plant some seeds
here and there and make people curious
but most often all these specially
nowadays intellectual debates that are
very popular this day and age and which
I enjoy myself but sometimes it just
boils down to intellectual masturbation
no offense but there's a deeper
component missing and really it ties
into what Gandhi said you know be the
change you want to see in the world
which that's saying has actually also
been distorted because you know what
change do you want to see so then people
again impose their own ideologies and
systems and and how things should be
right but the main ingredient is really
missing is what you just alluded to is
the deeper in a since yourself work to
really understand yourself like the
ultimate question Who am I to gain true
self-knowledge because all of us without
exceptions until unless someone is
enlightened
I'm not enlightened you know we all have
our own programming our own blind spots
on conditioning you know on various
levels just on the basic social level or
cultural level the way we grow up our
educational system which is most of this
is just an introductory nation so
certain believes ideas that don't really
you know a land of truth or reality I
mean look at that one of the basic
conditioning is you know when you
receive you know birth certificate and
birthdate birth certificate and passport
and right away you claim oh I'm an
American for those Bernie born here you
identify with this country with the
government with the flag with a nation
and there's earlier a conditioning
annotation artificial abstract concepts
to identify with you know these
imaginary borders and that already
creates separation through other people
identified conditioned with other
nations isms political systems flags and
whatnot right so you know but deep down
inside it comes to the question who are
we truly and and we are human beings but
we have certain identifications if
believes and ideas through our
upbringing and then through our bringing
some people
identifies the liberal left side
progressive Democratic side and then you
have the other side of the spectrum the
Republican right or whatever
conservative but it's like both you know
its ties in the trap of your
identification in a sense right and then
people trying to get to rid of the other
side or convince the other side right
there but it's a it's a closed loop
because it's in the center trap of this
duality so to speak so going beyond that
you know to truly have a better world or
want to see change we need to change DP
within ourselves before we can change
not just an action behavior so we need
to dive deep and dig within us and when
we do this sincerely we come across all
kinds of conflicting emotions desires
very disturbing feelings negative
feelings and stuff we don't really look
for love what to look at like stuff we
just like it just feels bad right and
then we suppress it we put it back in
the unconscious which Carl Jung called
the shadow right it gets oppressed
suppressed oppressed and then we
projected outward on other people with
emotional you know shadow projections
hate anger disgust everything that
irritates us about another person we get
offended by but you know Lutz to
actually what we have suppressed our own
unconscious shadow so this needs to be
come to life to become a whole person on
that basic psychological level right and
that includes childhood wounding no we
all have our issues no one is perfect
right neither our parents were not
perfect as well so you cannot blame your
parents because in the general
relational wounding and programming in
all of that but we're all dealing with
these emotions and feelings which we
have suppressed and and haven't allowed
us to feel and then we jump or escape
into the head and that's what's really
happening especially in this modern
world we live a very head centric
existence where the intellect the IQ is
worshipped information you see it in
school right of the grading system and
information and more but you know we're
not being taught anything about
emotional intelligence in school not
nothing about trusting your intuition
and diving deeper from there all right
and so what we experienced collectively
is also the body mind split
like we become disentis eyes from the
body the body holds an amazing
intelligent incredible intelligence and
awareness it gives us constantly signals
and signs what is good for us and what
is not good for us that intuitive
response which is unique to everyone
it's different right and the trap I see
nowadays as well as what I call the
disease of homogenization trying to make
everyone the same right which ties into
actually the underlying dogma of
socialism right or everybody should do
the same thing all these should-should
shirts and assuming that everybody is
the same what works for one may work for
everyone which is not true at all we are
unique individuals and what we're losing
is our individuality and I mean true
individuality in a sense of like who we
truly are a spiritual soul level a
unique expression of the divine of
something higher I'm not talking about
individuality and in terms of cultural
you know perception of of a cult of
personality which most often is a very
narcissistic personality which people
have as role models nowadays which we
see as celebrities or the Kardashian
kind of you know phenomenon you know
where people become famous just for
being famous and all these things but
there's a deep end of a true soul
essence right our true source within of
a ferment but also connects us to our
true soul purpose what we're here to do
on an individual level or vocation or
calling which is more than just a Korean
job right and the more we align with
that through this in a work and you know
get you know heal or get rid of anything
that is an obstruction in the way our
conditioning programming wounding the
more we've come in alignment with this
higher force with our true self so to
speak and then we receive an internal
guidance right and then life becomes
actually more effortless in the sense
and then we create more harmony that's a
true meaning of of reality creation the
more in harmony within ourselves with
nature and spirit the more it is
reflected in the outside world right but
we live in the modern world also again
and in a civilization that's completely
removed from nature and spirit right and
essentially our
embodied self so again being round
circle it is about this inner work which
is several aspects it's the self orgasm
aspect of a basic psychological level
like I said a young in psychology for
example like shadow work all of that
basic childhood ruining work right
anything wants trauma we have
experienced abuse from just you know
growing up or does living in the society
where pathology has become normalized
right there's this famous quote from
Krishnamurti it's no measure of health
to be well adjusted to a profoundly sick
Society and that's what we're trying to
do a lot of people that are trying to
adjust to a society that is completely
out of tune of nature's spur that is
pathological and a lot of people have
desires once in needs they take as their
own but they're not their own they are
deeply conditioned from entertainment
culture or whatever the tale is what
brings us happiness money Korea the more
you have that the more happy you will
but it's it's it's a bottomless hole
right it won't bring you true happiness
and then people pursue this and then
they get depressed and depression that
sense is actually not a physical or
mental illness it's the cry from the
soul to adjust right to go deep within
and find something else to question the
world as well you know once you do this
in a deeper inner process it also you
will start to see the world differently
start to question what we've been told
and told so it's a two-fold process it's
the inner and the outer work right
seeking truth you know within and
without so to speak and on that note I'm
not demonizing the intellect right it
has its place we need to learn how to
use the mind basic critical thinking
basic logic absolutely right but it has
its limitations right there's something
deeper that goes beyond the five senses
beyond the intellect you know which ties
in into deeper esoteric self work right
spiritual work embodiment process soul
evolution soul individualization right
reaching a high level of being of of
consciousness right which their
intellect their mind cannot grasp and is
actually hindrance in it so to speak but
the the key is again going into the body
to become truly whole also to unite the
inner male and female right the male
aspect is the head center
living the analytical the feminine
aspect is deep in the body in the gods
you know that's connected to all that is
that sees the interrelationship of the
doll the mind likes to fragment Heights
analyze right SEP separate everything
it's never perceiving wholeness
but then send everything the irony
everything what is here and what's
happening the world has its right to be
here and exist there's nothing wrong
with reality there's no mistake
everything has its teaching function
right and everything plays itself out in
this what we experience right now this
duality we're in right now all right so
it is you know that's in a nutshell this
this this process we you you know
whoever anyone who is called to do this
to really engage when this inner work
and obviously before you can do that you
also need to understand educates itself
how to do self work what does it imply
which implies having gaining a basic
understanding of of psychological work
somatic work the body-mind connection
and then understanding as a pterygoid
spiritual work meditative practices body
mind practices all of that all right to
get out of here because what I've
noticed the more people live up in the
head head centric existence the more
they look for answers out there for
somebody to tell them what to do and
that's actually the written rise of
authoritarianism to follow somebody to
somebody save the world because they've
lost their connection from within right
the more you have lost your own
connection the more you you know believe
in the illusion of government and
wanting a leader and somebody save them
all right the savior program
right and it's all by design from a
matrix perspective to not only
disempowers but vectors away from our
own guidance from our true soul deeper
purpose your nuance they're about soft
work is just that is why we're here
sitting with you today it's just
breaking it down in some of the most
just important highlights possible where
we're on this path to an awakening and
there is a lot of cultural programming
that comes in a place that like you were
saying vector us
of this path there is also this really
heavy process of looking at ourselves in
the mirror and being able to really help
ourselves objectively see what we want
to change and why we want to become
better how we want to guide ourselves
towards that awakening that we want to
have and then I think it's really
important you know as you were unpacking
all of this you started talking about
these vectors and even maybe just even
before we get there this really
relatable way that you were teaching me
about excuse me about artistic
expression so doing simple things like
both of us right now we're neither one
of us is wearing shoes right now we're
both absorbing sunlight right now we're
we were making some funny like artistic
expressions with like just making music
with our mouths earlier just this idea
that you can find you were talking about
body work as well that this sort of
these sort of easy things that are so
simple and grounding can help guide us
towards that self work maximizing the
success of it
other things like integrating the
wounding and aligning ourselves with
this path now maybe we talked a bit
about this vectoring so where we're on
this path and then there's these sort of
vectors that may come up and one of them
that you recently wrote about that I
think we both found very interesting was
the one about this inclination towards
objectification of women and that is
something that we see so much with men
occurring in the world and you know if
you see a very attractive woman the
first thing that you know really came to
mind is oh my gosh how attractive how
physically attractive my gosh sex sex
sex but then the ability to really grab
that and say hold on I'm not
objectifying what is going on in this
person's soul what is going on in their
heart let me practice that motion more
and more so it's maybe teach us a bit
about these vectors how they can of
course also hahaha we're in Tobago
actually we're so in Topanga I had this
little a court fall on me
from from the tree it was so great just
having a drop right in my lap so and the
vectors of course extend to so many
other things in culture so yes please
teach us about the vectors okay so you
mentioned several of things
yeah beyond like what do you mean in
grounding like simple aspects of just
also connecting more to nature as we are
right you know speaking of a grunt like
everything like literally walking
barefoot in the earth getting sunshine
there's a whole matrix program that
teaches fear of the Sun which is
completely based on lies the Sun has so
many health benefits and so many levels
of the energetic level there's proof of
physical benefits of strengthening
immune system the bones but also the or
on energetic level and it just keeps
your life and healthy it's the life
force literally right so doesn't that
they're just spending more time in
nature literally helps with that process
to get out of the cities to get out of
our mind right to jump into the ocean
ride and cleanse yourself and all the
things and essentially it's one a net
note it's not about also confronting our
you know wounded child but I was at the
joy of the inner child which we have
forgotten we've become such serious
adults you know even my work is serious
and people see you know I can see you
but you know some people think I'm a
very serious person I take my work
seriously but I don't take myself series
right I play I dance I love dancing
right I make music I like drumming and
and all these things when I jump into
the water the ocean I gig like a little
child because it reminds me of my
childhood water has such as this effect
to me and this joy of the inner child
right there's it also kind of that's
kind of out of us absolutely it's a
especially for men boys don't cry or
grow up you know being adult and I'm not
saying that we should be childish right
in the sense and avoid responsibility
that's not what I'm talking about
but it's you know that actually getting
in touch with our true the joy of an
inner child which has become so
suppressed in so many ways and armored
and buffered up is also the gateway to
all actually individual purpose in the
sense the vocation because remember new
in a
your child as I'm sure you can look at
certain things you always did and you
just love doing it if your whole passion
and your whole you were any anything
your whole being was interred and there
were two things you didn't care about
the outcome
they have no expectations of success
right of making money out of it in the
sense and also you didn't care what
anybody else was thinking about you
right and I'm not saying that this
particular thing is you thing but that
state you know whatever grabs you it's
what Joseph Campbell called following
your bliss that's the your vocation
that's kind of like that thing that
gives you so much power and excitement
that's the that's the hint to your
deeper soul purpose and it's not driven
by ambition it's not different by
expectations not driven by status and
what other people may think of you it
doesn't imply that you shouldn't make a
living out of it or receiving money for
this bad or evil the money's evil it's
just coming from this deeper sense of
being with integrity right and then the
universe would respond to call
accordingly and then you're truly living
your vocation rather than having just a
career a job but before you know some
people find it earlier than others right
but for that some most often it is
hidden behind all these layers of
insecurities woundings
you know conditioning programming and
all of that but you know like there's
wanted to acknowledge that that there
are simple ways we can do right to disk
to get out of their heads and disconnect
to nature now true selves but you know
if you don't you know if you don't
aspire to that then we get as you
mentioned vectored vector the way you
know through and if we're talking about
meaning you make this clear statement
about having more these hints these
hints towards our meaning and then the
vectors away from it exactly these hints
and they come Dec spirit nature the
divine whatever you may want to call it
I'm not talking about it dogmatic
religious God out there you know I'm
this you know the life source creator of
creation whatever it is talking to us to
you all the time is giving you sickness
and symbols it tells you gives you
messages but you cannot perceive it as
long as you're up here you're like box
of life
I have to do this and should do this and
all around the messages are there it can
be symbolism synchronicities a little
hint a little inspired intuition but we
don't have you forgotten to trust our
intuition oh we don't trust our
intuition because we've never taught to
trust our intuition and it's scary to
trust it intuition intuition is this
embodied knowing it's cause more than a
feeling and it gives you this really
embodied mmm-hmm or mmmm that's deep
embodied yes or no but it doesn't give
you a reason and we're so used when we
make decisions out of a head it's like I
should do this because ABCD pro and con
and like and then make this rationally
now and again I'm not demonizing that
right we need the planning practical
application but I the head is actually
the worst place to make decisions from
right it's more trust in this deep
embodied body's felt sense so to speak
knows what is good for us and when you
look at life life is all about making
decisions every single day the more you
get up in the morning till you make
decisions from big to small what to eat
what to wear up to like what
relationship to engage in what job to
have gone
take a trip yes no go to this to
anything right and most often it's so
mechanical so conditioned it's not only
it's like I mentioned before not email
our true self that is driving it but
it's the condition fake personality
right that false self so the more we
learn to trust within getting into body
and trusted intuition then we're more in
alignment and the less we get vectored
away or vectored off by matrix
temptation you know that I call
especially in culture which is the three
big ones it's money sex and power right
and again its Kiba it's nothing wrong
about money there's nothing wrong about
sex and there's nothing wrong about
power per se right you know money is
like greed upon exchange we have its
energy right but if if you just make
things just for the sake of money right
if that's your man then the matrix has
you so to speak and it will never give
you true fulfillment you know same with
powering with your power recognition
status right people to look and look at
me and like feed off of you did
but true power is internal it's
connected to your true divine source way
is so deeply fulfilled within that
nothing can shake you from the outside
you depend on the outside you don't
depend on anyone for your well-being and
and fulfillment and self-worth right and
sex well that's that's a whole topic on
its own what you just mentioned I mean
the sexual the distortion of sexual
energy is one of the underlying matrix
mechanisms so to speak you know to keep
us in his lower animalistic nature right
of sexual luge and you know a lot of you
know girge if said something profound in
this in the book his student PDA
Ouspensky wrote in search of the
miraculous there's a section about the
use of sex but the abuse of sex is not
necessarily all this sexual pathologies
that out there in this day and age which
you know but many of them have become
normalized but the use of sex and the
quote unquote wrong use of the distorted
use of the sexual center right when you
feed off of just sexual energy like a
lot of people to go out to parties even
shopping or whatever and dress up you
know most women and most remembered man
are like just to get a reaction to feel
like you know to be sexually you know to
be admired or like to kind of like feed
off of the attention you know on that
now it's very interesting we talk about
this because just two days ago I had a
session with like my healer and and and
and teach I go to sometimes because I
need feedback and healing work the long
session she did amazing and you know
energy work on me and I was this really
grounded highly aware state right and I
fasted all day so she lives down in West
LA so I step on the way back I went to
Santa Monica Third Street Promenade you
know that open-air mall so to speak and
so I was walking around the state and
was really fascinating and I was really
like observing people I'm trying to make
eye contact which didn't happen
everybody's in their own world reality
and and I had a sense very this deep
embodied experience how mechanical
people are like there's no free will
it's there are programs running around
and I didn't have any sense of
superiority right also complete
compassion which does Wow which is this
deep experience right and then I saw
also like at this there's not a sense of
superiority it's just a sense of
equality but also just of perceiving
things in this lens through this lens
exactly just to see what what as it is
like there was no thought like there was
a judge I didn't know there's no
judgment whatsoever just experiencing
that and it's more energetic level like
seeing through the appearance is seeing
wounded people mechanical people right
and on integrations of their childhood
traumas or maybe the attachments to the
appearance and to the need for that
sexual energy or to the attachments to
other things like you were describing
with the money and the greed these
things that you that if what would it
look like for all of those people that
you were walking by to be aligned
perfectly with their soul path and not
be vectored off yeah but with the
shopping mode will be empty but what
I've noticed in terms of sexual energy a
lot of guys too but most of them and the
way they dressed up and the makeup just
to go shopping to really like and the
sexual energy this louche was coming out
of them just to get that attention and
it was very consciously unconscious and
I'm again there's no judgement right but
it like I didn't feel attracted like
because I because I was like not in my
lower self I was really from this higher
embodied perspective right but most of
we live in this lower nature animalistic
being you know of fight and flight
[ __ ] and eating basically you know
what most be like unconsciously you know
are driven by so to speak and you know
but again there was no judgment it see
what it is but I see this so much in our
world like again with which especially
nowadays of women are subjected to what
you mentioned the objectification right
specially in this day and age with the
internet the the impossible body image
porn and all of that you know and man
feed under that as well so everybody is
there's it's not about gender
you know in general but it's everybody's
wounded so to speak right so there needs
to be a lot of healing and it's also not
demonizing sexuality or beauty you know
it's okay to appreciate physical you
need to take care of yourself on the
physical level absolutely right that's
that's you know if you want to pump
yourself up or a nice cloth make some
makeup you know that go for it right
enjoy yourself right but what is the
true intention behind it again right
what are you trying to achieve you know
what you're trying to get out of it
right so it is about essentially true
self love but not the narcissistic kind
of self love we get addicted to the
compliments of other people and then you
have the whole selfie generation and
narcissism social media and people
getting addicted to the dopamine hits of
all the likes they're getting off of
their selfies and all of that all right
that's not self-love that narcissism
right that's that's an epidemic
literally whether that has become
normalized as well because of what I
mentioned before of role models in our
official culture who are fallen artists
right what would you what would you say
for the for the truth seekers that are
that are on the soul path that are that
at least are aware of the soul path that
see the vectors coming in that are
trying to ship them off the soul path
the control matrix what are you know you
were listing at the very beginning these
ways of looking at ourselves in the
mirror integrating our trauma all these
different things what is kind of the you
know the coalescing thought around that
you've been with the guts to how to do
it yeah well first understanding it's a
process right and you know it's ties
into the process of awakening right
essentially and you know the true
awakened state we're talking about
enlightenment so that's far away from
all you know it's right here about far
away at the same time again I'm not
awake and fully awakened a true meaning
of the word right there's different
levels and stages it's a process to
become more more objective with our
selves
a more objective of the world true
objective Vienna cannot be fully
objective I will have a subjective blind
spots but the Leiden State is three like
when the observer become the observed
and us to see the universe as it sees
itself you know like it's hard to put
into words and the mind because it's
like you don't want to mistake them as
the Zen saying goes the finger pointing
at the moon for the moon right or the
dour that can be named it's not the
Taoist so language has its limitations
here obviously but it's a process Trust
starts its basic self observation and
the big part of it is to to establish
the observer in the objective observer
the witness within that's the foundation
to start from in terms of self work
through meditative self observation to
be able to not dissociate out of your
head but you're able to look at yourself
from the outside and see how you act how
you feel what and you see a whole always
conflicting emotions how mechanical it
is really right and what is truly
driving it and with what you know I mean
like you said before when you see a
beautiful women sometimes the men have
the neck whoa well alright and you see
like most men or people don't question
their to act on it and it's mostly
justice like just the sexual desire this
is aroused it's lower it has its extra
biological function to mate right in a
sense right but it has become over
sexualized right and all of that but if
you like you manage to observe yourself
like okay it's interesting like you
don't necessarily act until you
understand this is a very mechanical
biological impulse in that sense that
has been abused by the matrix
advertising uses a lot sex cells we know
it right because it makes you feel
better you specifically reference this
is basic self work this basic self
looking at yourself in the mirror and I
think that is a right spot on this
practice of this feedback loop of
observing oneself objectively and
working on oneself towards their higher
calling all these vectors I'm really
excited for you to for you to share the
webinar and one one last thing I think
is really important for us to talk about
right now you and I had this
conversation earlier
and we find it to be quite in it's quite
disheartening it's a it's actually a
little bit frustrating we see a lot of
leading figures that are that however
that are getting so much praise in their
pursuits we see you know you know a
mosque in many ways in the other grass
tyson in other ways and join petersen
different ways and so we were just
talking about these figures and just how
unfortunately none of them can for some
reason attack the control matrix that
none of them can badmouth the control
matrix because then their following
would question them you unpack that for
us because we want to rebirth the public
intellectual we want to make it easy for
for people to be able to talk about at
whatever scale whatever they want
especially critiquing the control matrix
and transcending it and helping people
unleash their souls how can we make that
happen
yeah well first of all regarding
individuals you mentioned that i've seen
them in very different quote-unquote
categories without judging unlike you
know you know Neil deGrasse Tyson it's
for me like a gatekeeper to keep for
keep the soldiers of scientism so to
speak right main some science and liking
you know had some great things to say
but there's some scientific dogma so to
speak right and I want to there's no
need to get into bait into him ala mask
you know we talked about it as you know
the technocrats Savior that he's hailed
as there's some issues and I wrote an
article about it with transhumanism in
AI and what he kind of promotes it falls
into the hey Gary Gallion dialect of
problem reaction solution there's an
article on my website people can talk
with check out transhumanism the trap of
consciousness
Jordan Peterson is in a different
category I feel he has it's play he has
his plays that have placed in a very
important role all right it's an
interesting it got so popular and here's
some great many things to say to
counteract they're really that
pathological left right and a right away
is branded as a right wing and what like
the say me when I criticize liberals
whatever I'm right called a trump
supporter when I couldn't care less
about either side because I know the
status and
government nations and all of that or
political affiliations whatsoever right
but even like John Peterson this
interesting he became extremely popular
right but the more popular you become
the less and less you were able truly to
stay in integrity and really seek truth
and speak out about topics that may be
even more to boo than what he is already
talking about because he would get an
immense attack and be destroyed right
and I'm also not sure how he is actually
aware of these deeper levels and I'm not
saying that I know it all I'm all fully
aware you know if my own and it's my
process but I just know my workers be
speak out about topics that would
definitely rise and highbrow to say the
least it would be more on on the
mainstream level right and I would
that's why my work is not for everyone
if one reached the mainstream and if it
would be like I tell my friends like out
of joke Nia if I ever end up on Oprah
like you know give me rare something is
off I have failed right so but you know
that's how the matrix keeps itself in
control
all right look at 9/11 the big lies
still you know even by basic logic basic
critical thinking the official story
doesn't hold up but ever seventeen years
is still up and if you in a position of
high public exposure and popularity you
would question that you get shut down
right you know like it's a can of worms
if Jordan Peterson no likes you know
Moscow whoever these individuals or any
of he's more popular intellectuals would
start questioning these things they
would get a lot of attacks and be shut
down and all the inner would you know so
it is you know that's why I'm always you
know once you reach a certain level of
attention right there's like the matrix
kind of wraps down more on me on
yourself so to speak right it's up to us
to then drive these questions to them
individually like for neil degrasse
tyson is there too much of an obsession
with scientism that there's not enough
of an openness to spirituality with you
or maybe with Elon Musk
it's about the ability
to talk about the really really
difficult conversation about AI and
transhumanism and how we still have a
long way to go for us to understand
ourselves and then the merging with
machines is a very insanely crazy thing
that needs to be unpacked much more
before we advanced technology just to
get there just to do it and then maybe
with Jordan its what are those other
taboo areas that you just can't talk
about like why can't we open up more of
society to be able to talk about those
things well a lot of these topics it's
like they are cold topics hidden topics
a cold simply means hidden right and by
the nature of it you know requires a
certain level of being and awareness and
embodiment beyond intellectual you know
mastery to understand and to perceive
them so you cannot just convince people
intellectually about certain topics you
know there's always discussion like the
latest was I think Jordan Peterson
versus sam Harris and it's like I was
listening to it and it's it's fun to
watch but again it's for me it's like my
intellectual masturbation it's a waste
of time right because it's like I don't
I don't want to convince people that
there's something else higher a force a
divine force acting like but there's
nothing with the religious God it's a
it's a deeper you know experience right
you cannot convince people by argument
it's a waste of time right simple things
that we were describing at the beginning
with the being in the sunlight doing
body work music dance artistic
expression those types of things get you
closer to that feeling yeah absolutely
especially you know you get more in the
zone you go on and you know session I
mean it do truly in artistic expression
whatever life is art in the sense that
it's about being in the zone you
understand from a higher perspective
that your transducer for a higher force
for the Diwani you're just a vessel
under the illusion of separation you
identified with this ego personality
which is not who you truly are you know
know you these I'm talking about that
now giving intellectual concepts and but
this is an inner experience and that's
only result can be experienced when you
engage in this what I mentioned before
in our work that esoteric work the great
work of the alchemists what it's called
about
right developing yogic consciousness
which is yoga goes way beyond just doing
the asana practice well it's it's it's
Yoga means literally union with the
divine mind and see it through all as a
tarik teachings but the problem is again
being stuck in the head right there's
emotional intelligence missing there's
more deeper sensitivity missing this
this head centric existence right so I'm
all for intellectual discourse and it's
great what's happening there on their
level I enjoy it but it's it's it's it's
limited and it's a trap in itself people
definitely need to understand again I
mentioned before have basic critical
thinking right which especially left me
seems to be completely missing we talked
about this before the straw man
arguments all kinds of logical fallacies
which need to be understood right and
and and and being able to talk about
things without getting taking things
personal engaging it at how men and
personal attacks and all of that or
being offended and all this nonsense
right but this is just a step right
there's something else something deeper
and like you cannot people have to waken
up will waken up in their own terms you
cannot force other people to wake up you
know I nobody forced me nobody tried to
talk me into it and one one's the nuance
of life the new ones of life and I
mentioned this maybe before suffering I
suffer deeply that was my trigger my
catalyst I didn't fit in you know I was
unhappy I was depressed despair didn't
if suicide that started debt created the
call within me Who am I what is this
world what's going on that was the seed
right so and and a lot of people do
suffer but they don't know that they
suffer but they have buffered up with
Armour with addictions with this
external distractions entertainment
internet sex addiction shopping you know
it's not only drugs and alcohol so we
just you know avoid our own
disillusionment it's so unfortunate that
those buffers are not being torn down by
the leading intellectuals and and
spiritual people and personalities our
athletes and artists and actors and
actresses businessman
all these leading figures have so much
following so much potential from these
corporations as well to shatter the veil
and pierce through the veil and we're
not doing that fully yet but we're well
on our way and veil of reality comm
links in the bio subscribe to a Bernards
mailing list Barnard will be sending out
the link for his webinar soon and what a
freaking pleasure yeah the webinar
you're looting - that's it's it's a long
one it has deep into more e'terica cold
topics into what I come with the shamans
called the topic of all topics the hyper
dimensional matrix control system in
particular cold forces hidden forces
that interfere with us from other realms
entity attachments right so the topic is
about that webinars about that in terms
of this
he's a discernment protection and
clearing and again that's probably more
quote-unquote an advanced webinar for
people who may be already aware of it
but you know anybody can check it out so
more information and once I announce it
on my website yes it's such a pleasure
thank you again for coming in onto the
show again talking to us at your
beautiful home in Topanga Canyon thanks
everyone for tuning in if you guys had a
good time definitely give us some
comments below we would love to hear
your thoughts about this episode also
don't just consume this content go and
create with it go and write about it go
make video about it go and create things
with it we'd love to see those creations
as well and much love everyone thank you
for tuning in and we'll see you soon
peace